and
pawn to e5 bishop f5 pawn to h4
aronia going for broke
queen to c8 and pawn to h5
queen c8 i've seen recently who played
this artemia
say logical
um
looks a little slow can we change the
wonder to
2.5 is that possible chat is getting a
little too excited
uncle indigo was saying jan is winning
me over at first i didn't like the
whispering
but low-key funny guy thanks uncle
indico
that means a lot
they're getting a somewhat weird
french structure
where the plus side for black is
that the light square bishops got
exchanged
plus for white is that he grabbed a lot
of space with the pawn on h5 already
and usually if you ask engines i'm
always surprised by this because i
grew up thinking if you get rid of the
so-called fret
bat of the fret bench bishop
then you should be doing great here with
black
but computers still think that why it's
just better in these kinds of situations
especially if there's not enough
pressure on the center
yeah i still find it hard to accept
looks like black has space for all his
pieces
should be doing fine
and more moves have been made
because i'm trying to get the pieces out
concluded the king is safer
on the queen side then on the king side
very sharp position now
white somewhat weakened his kings
set up as well with this pawn on g4
i don't know still feels easier for
black to play carson goes
c4 another idea borrowed from the french
now the y plane a3 makes it harder for
white
to open the position computer says y is
just winning which
i'm confused by
but here we are one
sorry guys that i told you what the
computer says i will no longer
um pretend that the computer
assessment is my own assessment by
saying
computer says
twitch chat
bishop f2
create ana
still doesn't look that clear
but with white having all these units
on the site computer
is still very very optimistic for what
okay shade plate
clever romeo has a lot of time played
this very quickly
seems to just believe in the white
structure
and seems to know what he's doing here
some decisions to make now knight f6
is a move he would think about at least
i should have
six ef then how does black
save this knight
saying c2 was a mistake i think
what do you mean queen c2 why did you
mean c4
um levon is taking on h4
and goes gf5 so he doesn't try to trap
this knight it just exchanges it
tries to open the position on the king's
side using his superior number
of pieces in play there
it's not that superior but the knight on
c6 arguably a little far away rook g7
very deep
asking this knight to join the action
computer not a big fan
of this move king a6
queen a4 checks not mate there's two
knight a5
21 are deep luring this knight further
away from the king's side
before switching to direct battle here
die hex one is saying england bigger
german
extremely well put diax one
rook g8
if you wonder what that lovely singing
outside is
i don't know it could be anybody
rook g6 bishop g5
nice little trick by magnus separating
the queen
from the rook
and forcing the rook to retreat
to g7 or to go back to g7 it's not
really retreating
queen b5 magnus changing directions
the queen is fishing for food on b2
queen e2 covers it but now bishop f4
he's just so sharp he's in shape and he
seems in great shape today
the world champion
amazing board vision just as i praise
him he goes bishop g5
which the computer is not a big fan of
probably because it lets
this e-pawn roll freely
still looks like anything could happen
frankly queen c6
knight f3 can you take the
question was if there's checkmate here
knight b8
if it takes you lose the quaint so you
have to go king b5
and a4 king a4 i don't see it
and yeah neither of us live on aronia
goes knight fe-5
the andrew was very excited about
something so probably that was a direct
way
f4
queen h5
yeah this whole game seems like a total
mess according to the engine
aronia missed plenty wins but there was
nothing
i would say
should have spotted that one it's just
chaos and now carson survived
it's an end game and all of a sudden
only black can be better because the b2
pawn is the weakest pawn on the board
the king is coming
carlson has spotted
the way to get to it
he's going to think if he should start
with b5 but b5 does knight c7 so he's
gonna start by taking
i don't know if this is winning for
black but it looks very very close a5
surprising move why not just king b3
it's giving up this form there is a plan
it's so good even with no time in these
ncaas
must be nice
cousin too strong today
this is just winning now d6 you take
by king c3 11 aronian resigns the game
where he had plenty of chances i want to
see this one moment